然然要怎么开心你的服务业
老规远就想到什么说什么
做服务业一定不是靠情愿
愿情愿情
因为那相当于你不过就是
多打得一份公耳以吗
一定是投入产出闭衣服匹贝
我一旦直播的时候有个老伙伴
在香港留言说
抱怨
投入产出闭衣服匹贝
你要做的就是不匹贝的事
如果批贝的话
一份公耳以份说
那一位啥
一位这你不公耳以就没说话
靠停手停嘛
对吧
所以一定要做这个投入产出闭
不匹贝的事
那小人说
我是十分公耳以一份说话
那你就想想为什么呢
既然你已经知道这个地
是十分公耳以一份说话了
但你为什么不换个地中呢
是谁主海的你
找到这个主外你的人
你组组织
所以做负业一定是靠系统
不是靠世界
那怎么靠系统呢
给大家分享两个王宝宝宝手行第一个
把你过去所有的经历
就是你做事的经验一些方法呀
对你有帮助的
哪怕在小时
你把他全部列出来
为什么因为可能别人也需要呢
对了几个例子
我直播的时候就几个一个小例子
比如说很多年轻人
十六岁岁的小男孩
而且他长到这个满脸的清分之后
但是你用了一个什么的方法
你会发现就没有这个声音到了
你觉得现在
对我这样的超老爷们
他可能不之前
但是对于政治十六岁岁岁的满脸长得清分之后的小男生来说
这个是
非常非常的重要
你会发现这个经验对别人几个帮助
所以你把你自己的
过往的所有的
你觉得是经验或者对我帮助当时你
用了一个什么的方法
你把它分享出来
比如你帮了一个让更多的人看到
你会发现这就是你的开始
几个方向
首先第一个呢
就是你以前是我经验的
把这个经验的复本
分享出来
就像刚才我说的
其实就是对吧
经验的复本分享出来
你分享完了以后没有
也没什么水是吗
一个一个的城市
第二个的话就是你把一个技能
做成产品对外分享
这个在我们说出那边已经出现了
因为有的时候我经常会给老伙你们演说
怎么十万一来的
我怎么通过AI去整理知识了
然后获得动天的
然后又不给大家去讲这个台的读作
我觉得太简单了
然后我们很多老伙就干嘛呢
就有老伙就
就把怎么把我的这个
露音
做发成文字
怎么通过一个一个一段内容
生成动艳
AI的提了死发方法
就做成了一块
一点点产品
我看也收拾快两个死了
你会发现
就有人
开始购买了
这就是两号的开端
就是你做的工具对边有帮助
我边不会吧
你用这个工具可以
很方便的就是用特的
把你的经常装发成
产品我的工具
那第三种的话
你自己是特别爱股工具的
那么普通工具的工具的工具的话
可能就会有些模板
这些模板对边有帮助
今天早期很能用平平地经常用
可以可以规暴
那批平地做的不好看
批平地的模板
对吧
我经常会写游战
这个游战
怎么才能做得更好
这个游战的模板
这把怒身模板
这些东西都可以销售的
对吧
所以各位
总决你过往的
所有的经验
你可以把这个亲验
不卖经验
卖负败
让你有体能
不卖技能
把技能做成产品的方案销售
如果你经常把
我能一些工具
对吧
你把你把这个工具做成一些模板
比如听模板
什么游战模板
什么都什么模板
你可以对外销售
这是第一步
这是第一种模板
那很能说
我没什么东西可以
可以对外生响的
你可以用
然后给你个更继续的方法
你想干什么
不要定那个常量的情况
我觉得定个一年的三年的
短了六个月的
都可以
自己定个计划
比如说像现在
把比如说像专钱
都可以定一个计划
定完这个计划以后
然后你可以做一个产品
比如说你想写败数
比如说
我如何写败
写败数
我如何专钱写败数
那很能说
我还不会的专钱
当然
进入因为你不会才写败数
你会来就不会不用写
那么写数
那可能是我不会
我写数的那个数
不是害人吗
对了
因为这个数出来以后
让别人要看
到看到以后要实操
要有用
而且真的
不会让别人慢一
怎么办
那你写这个东西
真的要有
能让人转到钱
所以你就要去分节
然后市面上
都有那些转钱的方法
把它理论出来
管理论不行
你这就时间
时间完以后
是不是这样的
我通过这样一个方法
正好多少钱
然后从应用回忆规理论
我在实际的识操的公众中
我就到底懂什么所
有理论有案例
有市场
有数据
多方法
就去写这样的数
一个方法
两个方法
三个方法
有
整个下来
这本数写完了
说出不出版不重要
你肯定能转到钱的
给你明白我的意思吗
你想干什么
三个月
六个月一年
想干什么
确定能转
然后就赶这个事吧
每天去干一点点
比如的音
怕了一个
然后想办法把这个身族号
这个钱就抓的
这就是你的呼应
所以从现在开始
每天至少抽出半个小时
一个小时
怕怕是时的
去购务天你自己的成品
一点一点完成
把它做小做好做完整
如果你能像我一样
每天显然一直
每天拍 transmitter是 bring
找到你一个方向
你觉得这么做
我跟你讲
你一定会觉得穿底的
必须的
必须的避
是吧
为什么
给我跟你大гор影响吧
这个事件上
百分之90的人
是不学习不思考的
剩下的百分之10里
被有百分之十
50的人
不会思考的
思考干ya不明白的
然后生命的那个百分之事里面还要百分之有神做到一半就推作的
只要你能做到
你就比别人强
我今天跟很多老伙子讲说我说
如果是普通人
你一个普通人啊你们跟我说活得和我
该创业我还要找个班上啊
咱俩没想关系
那我就告诉你
去去上班去
你适合上班
这个万一你创业十八两天还找我
但是如果你是我自己的
地美我的辞职
你问我
我应该是创业还是上班
滚出去
创业
为什么
我们大部分人平衡的原因是什么
第四也不开构
不知道百分之有什么东西
对你只能走到你
务力所谓的地方吗你都不知道百分之有啥你当然做不到了
第2个每天在重复
大量的
没什么技术含量的工作
对吧你每天干的事
进天干的事和明天干的事
没啥区别
干五年
和干五个月
除了有点
这个熟练度和人情事故事外没什么变化
这是我们很多人的建装
而且做那个事也没什么
也没什么气势还量
就找个人就可以
就可以把你提带了
这是不是什么好的人
特别害怕领导啊
一定要注意人情事务啊
是吧
他领导给你参想一下原因是什么呀
你的替代的成本
太低了
所以就是我跟大家很多人说
为什么很多人
就干五年和干五块月没什么差别
但是如果你去创意
只要你不把自己不要去负卉你去尝试
哪怕你失败了
你的事业
你的知识的秘读你思考你的方式都不一样
然后你会发现在那些人去那个
你必然赫了几须呢
你就知道
你就必须你的思想
你的想法你的行动力
是高一节的
所以个月从现在开始想想
你未来三个月六个月一年你要干什么事
然后从现在开始
每天
前进
一点点
比如
YM
Public